that was the moment when his opponent  actually designed yeah it's it was  probably a better position than this one  that only has  yeah  okay so  he'll um  he'll just push h3 and then  rook p2 would be my guess and king g3  no like h3 and then bishop g3 which one  on bishop g1  uh then also e2 oh yeah g2 yeah  so this is  it's  um  much over  wow  okay i don't think i'll stay to watch  the final agony  no i mean i was hoping for unish to  design so that we can ask you some  questions you know  because otherwise it would have been  unpolite towards pragya that is he's  about to beat anish and we are not  focusing on his game that's it  all right so tanya now you have  green lines